in this video we're going to talk about
why
Transformations sometimes have the
opposite effect so let's dive into this
video what does that mean
Transformations and what does it mean
having the opposite effect well let's
take a look at a parent function like
this yalun x function we can get a nice
table here by plotting some uh points
and let's put some values in for X that
are easy to take the square root of
like0 1 4 and 9 the square of 0 is 0er
square of 1 is 1 square of 4 is is 2 squ
9 is 3 now let's take a look at a
function that has been transformed a
square root function that has been in
this case shifted and when we look at
this xus 2 let's again make a table but
let's pick some values that are going to
make this easy to take the square root
of so for example I could put in two 2 -
2 is 0 and the square root of 0 is 0 or
I could put in 3 3 - 2 is 1 the square
of 1 is 1 or I could put in six uh 6 - 2
is 4 the squ of 4 is 2 and I can put in
11 11 - 2 is 9 squ of 9 is 3 now let's
go ahead and plot these points on this
graph let's graph the parent function
first so that's going to be here at 0 0
1 4 2 and
93 and that's like our basic graph right
there but let's look what happens with
this xus 2 when we plot these points so
here we have 2 comma 0 I'll just put in
x 3 comma
1 uh 6 comma 2 see 2 3 4 5 6 two is
right about here and Etc so basically
what you can see is this graph looks
something like that so what's actually
happened in this situation here well you
can see that this original graph has
shifted to the right two units but when
you look at the equation you might be
saying to yourself Mario it's xus 2 why
is it shifting to the right two why is
it having that opposite effect of what
you would think you think minus two
would be left two right so if you look
at the table here you can see that in
order to get an output of zero the x
value had to be two more than in the
parent function same thing over here see
in order for this to yield an output or
a y-value of three the x value actually
had to be two units more see 11 and so
that's why the graph is actually
shifting to the right too the way I like
to think about it is when it's group
with the X whether it's inside of the
parentheses with the x or underneath the
square root or in the absolute value
bars but it's grouped with the X I know
it's going to affect the xaxis direction
this horizontal Direction but it's going
to have the opposite effect if it's not
group with the like if it was you know
adding one or if you had a two out here
in front that's going to affect the Y
values let's look at another uh example
so we're going to still work with this
parent function the square root function
but now let's look at y equals the
square root of 2x so what do you think
is going to happen in this situation
well let's make a table again and I'm
going to put values in for X that are
easy to uh take the square root of so if
I put in 0 2 * 0 is 0 and the square of
0 is 0 if I put in a half 2 * a half is
1 and the sare of 1 is 1 if I put in two
2 * 2 is 4 and the square of 4 is 2 and
if I put in 4.5 2 * 4.5 is 9 and the
sare of 9 is 3
now let's go ahead and plot this table
and the original parent function table
on this graph here so starting with the
parent function we've got 0 0 1 1 4 2 5
6 7 8 9
3 and so there's our
original graph like so whereas if I
plant plot these points we've got 0 Z
which is at the origin 1 12 1 is right
here uh 22 is right here
4.5 uh three is right here so this
graph looks something like this now
what's happening in this case well you
can see here it's like we're squeezing
on this parent
function in the horizontal Direction so
this is actually a horizontal shrink of
one half not two you would think two
would be like a horizontal stretch by a
factor of two but it's the opposite what
I mean by the opposite in this case is
instead of multiplying by two you're
dividing by two or you can think of it
as multiplying by the reciprocal a
horizontal shrink of 1/2 now you might
be saying Mario why is that well notice
here on the table see in order to get a
y value or an output of one the x value
had to be half as much as over here see
in order to get an output or a y-value
of two the x value had to be half as
much see this was two this was four same
thing here this is 4.5 this is N9 so it
looks like when you look at the equation
that you're doubling but what's
happening is that the x value has to be
half as much to yield that same output
and so graphically what that does is it
actually shrinks it horizontally so
great job if you were able to follow
these examples but if you want to see
more which I highly recommend follow me
over to my recent video here talking
about Transformations where we talk
about not just the stretching and
shrinking but the reflections
translations
Etc follow me over that video we'll get
some more practice I'll see you there